[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Nick friedel covers the NBA for ESPN
he's covering the heat during the NBA
Finals joining us on the program Nick
good morning
um if I'm a Miami Heat fan give me a pep
talk after last night
you got Jimmy Butler he's going to play
a lot better than he did Noah went to
the foul line two times Dan which is a
postseason record and there was no
lack of confidence in that locker room
last night they felt like they didn't
play well there's still a little bit of
a hangover coming off that Boston series
as far as all the minutes everybody went
through and they feel like they're going
to be fine but I tell you watching jokic
you can say you're going to be fine and
then you look down and he's got six
shots in the third quarter and he's
dominating the game and you go uh oh so
this is definitely going to be the the
toughest task that they've had on this
run I was wondering and I'm racking my
NBA Rolodex of how many players great
players have the less they shoot the
more dominating their team can be
because Steve Nash was like that with
Phoenix that D'antoni would encourage
him to shoot more but I saw where Joker
has two 12 shots
but I didn't it's not like I go oh my
God they're shutting him down it's
almost like that's what his game plan is
like I'm going to get everybody involved
whereas if you said Jimmy Butler is
going to have 14 shots then I know
Miami's in trouble
can you think of somebody who maybe
Magic Johnson but the less they shot the
more it felt like their team was going
to have a great performance it's
certainly magic but then in this era I
can't think of anybody else and the
scariest part to your point is that
before the series started bam maravio
said what we need to do is limit Joker's
passing yeah and you're thinking you
know what he can do 20 25 points in the
blink of an eye but he said that once he
gets passing and he opens up the lane
for everybody else that's when you get
into big trouble against Denver and he's
right and I asked him last night well
how do you do that and he said well you
just gotta stay in front of him and and
keep him right where you can see him
again easier said than done so I think
they're going to be looking at that film
hard in the next couple days and the
scary part for Miami is I'm not sure
there's an answer because the rest of
the league hadn't figured one out either
I don't know if Denver played great last
night Nick
I mean that should be factored into this
you know when Joker comes out uh you
know they struggle a little bit Miami
came back and I know Miami didn't get to
the free throw line but that's because
if you're gonna fall in love with the
three and you're not hitting the three
you're gonna die by the three and you're
not going to get to the free throw line
Jimmy Butler's got to get to the to the
basket he's got to get to the free throw
line I mean I I don't understand the
logic of today's NBA it's keep shooting
threes because you know you know
eventually you're gonna make them and
then come back until you don't make them
and you're the Boston Celtics
then not only did Denver not play that
well but again if you're looking at this
from Miami's perspective what has
carried them through the postseason
aside from Jimmy's dominance at times
especially against the Bucks in the
first round all those guys were hitting
shots from all over the place Max struce
who was over 10 last night Caleb Martin
who was awesome against the Celtics in
the Eastern Conference Finals he's one
for seven Duncan Robinson didn't shoot
it well Gabe Vincent is still dealing
with a little bit of an ankle injury and
he shot it all right but can you trust
them night tonight and what we saw last
night is when you aren't hitting from
all over and Jimmy's not creating that
space and you're just letting bam
offensively do whatever he kind of wants
he can score a lot of points and they
were still never really in the game so
there were always flaws within this
Miami roster they were covered up by the
fact that they were knocking down shots
over the last few weeks but when that
doesn't happen you see a game like we
saw last night more likely for a sweep
or a seven game series after what you
saw last night all right I say this is
somebody who is bet against Jimmy Butler
at every step in this playoffs and all
he does is laugh at me so I would tell
you that I think it's gonna be a sweep
with what we saw and with the limited
other options Miami has but Dan if I've
learned anything in the last six weeks
or so being around this team it said
just when you count them out and just
when you think ah I don't see it I don't
see how they could turn this around they
have always found a way so it was
interesting to me being in there that
they were all like ah Caleb Martin
called it a figure it out game he said
we gotta just keep figuring out what we
need so I think they got another couple
in them but as we sit here right now I'd
be really surprised if they won this
series and I look at Jimmy Butler as a
person and a player similar to Kauai
like they're they're kind of mysterious
they're not user friendly with the media
uh they're big in big games can you see
a correlation Maybe a comparison between
those two I can admit the ability to
raise the level of their own games in
some of the biggest games but then what
I tell you because I covered Jimmy from
day one back in the Chicago days when I
was around the Bulls Jimmy says he
doesn't care and that they don't pay
attention to what he said well that's
completely ridiculous he knows exactly
what's said he knows exactly who's
saying it he knows how many different
people have been against him have been
against his team have said he can never
be the face of a title team and never be
the leader that he's turned into at
times with this group so I do think that
by choice he doesn't put everything out
there but to think that he totally
blocks everything out and just doesn't
care that's not right at all
good to visit with you Nick thanks for
joining us and Dan is a proud Orlando
native thanks for the music at the top I
appreciate that I remember seeing the
backstory boys that Sing the anthem at
Orlando Solar Bears game so that was a
nice walk down memory lane uh best
Florida band worst Florida band
I I was never an O-Town fan in the
amount of dates that I took to NSYNC
concerts at the old Orlando arena was
was pretty impressive so I'd have to go
there so I know all the words to all the
songs but I don't think I could fully
commit to being a a major fan of any one
band well if I gave you Creed or Limp
Biscuit
Scott Stapp went to my high school he
went to Lake Highland in Orlando so if I
go against free I'm going against like
30 years of alumni so I guess Korean but
uh it would be it would be tight there
thank you Nick you got uh Nick friedel
he's covering the NBA Finals covering
the heath during the finals for the
mothership there yep